hello and welcome to this video
Cheska gets chest boss and says who I'm
on TV
yep that's probably right if you call
YouTube TV so got a Rosso limo with
night to d4 Knight to d4 is a rare move
because there is a pawn structure that
is usually considered to be quite
favorable for white so let's see it got
more than one way to play this this is
one that I like playing a little bit in
the style of the Grand Prix attack but
claiming that this pawn structure
transformation wasn't to blacks
advantage okay so I got the e5 here
instead of move e5 it's a bit it's a bit
uncommon that you actually managed to
play this you know not not certainly I'm
not sure about it I probably I can it's
a temple gainer but he will after e5
returns and d6 he will check my center
anyway so what is he going to play here
Knight c5 probably I'd like to keep that
bishops it's a it's a pretty nice Bishop
so I'm going to invest this tempo
yeah it's kind of normal to play the
Queen over to H form didn't go for f5 so
going to go for that plan
typical Grand Prix plan in the Grand
Prix attack however you usually don't
have this double point situation here
it's not like that the pawns are problem
and it's how we just said the pawn on d4
is just yeah like stopping the bishop
there should be six is interesting here
no
yeah Queen h4 is a tempo and I think I'm
going for that it's I mean maybe he just
goes east 6 cm and claims that you know
and claims that I need annoyed for the
for these attacks to be successful maybe
but I think I think I'm okay I've got f5
still on the cards difficult for him to
prevent us yeah this is a move that I
felt shouldn't be good but maybe it is I
mean look at that diagonal yeah but
maybe it is not that bad ok takes with
the rook ok I didn't expect that thought
with the G porn but okay at least now I
know where where my play is I'm going to
try to pile up only six
oh that's an interesting move probably a
good move okay dissipate that maybe but
maybe still six is too weak area
wait-wait-wait were related we're not so
not so fast his rook has no square
if I'm the queen that say to Age 3 and
threatening to play g-form
[Music]
yeah let's do that
and then think about the rest you know I
kind of expected that to happen it's
it's another weakening move and now I go
look f2 he might actually yeah I cannot
believe she five no that would be a
little bit much where people play like
that act like the most ambitious I mean
oh no I can take I can just take it
sorry
like when f2 the rook is not that well
protected
you know Canada I don't care so much can
even go before in this position
on the other hand what do I care about
to be to pawn really okay so let's keep
it and now he's got 93 mm but I have to
take it which is not really what I
wanted to do okay it's not good it's
really not ideal now mine API should I
should be better somehow after you
played so many weakening moves and I'm
not better
whoa okay
mm yeah it's see no way forward him
unfortunately
yeah yeah I can't do much it's just I
think roughly equal this pollution I
don't know what does he want to do that
the sacrifice we should have form now
come on
I don't think I mean maybe maybe he can
play it somehow but I don't think it
should should we know anything no let's
go okay
mmm I would love to play before but I
cannot oh really I don't see when that's
not good hey I don't see when it's a
funny funny way to put it how do I draw
this
okay now I'm winning I think I was a
silly move
to song I hope ok I'm not losing but I'm
probably also not winning cannot go c4
here huh
what c3 no oh what a shame what a shame
ok Wow and winning is kind of
heartbreaking I mean you really should
not should not draw this position but
probably it was a bad idea to trade
rooks yeah all of a sudden it got really
problematic ok so let's say if we start
roughly Here I am I think this is a
really nice position and I didn't quite
make yeah didn't quite do the right
thing sim Queen g3 is better
yeah maybe f5 is a tempo and no before
over oh my god no oh yeah well it's
early in the day but I can at least see
the little things simple things and like
he just resigns the game I mean look at
five before I didn't didn't occur to me
at all I mean I kind of I kind of
registered that this f4 field is right
it maybe maybe subconsciously yeah I was
saying then he took this and before he
just resigns the game in Knight is
attacked and this is just over it's very
silly so the game should have been
overwhelming for 18 okay it wasn't so I
mean he I'm also better but not not like
winning or anything
that was a bad move probably am Bishop
Siwon is just stronger I guess keeping
this covered
the engine is also green this is all of
a sudden failed okay for black young I
couldn't really claim anything however I
think he somehow played in a way that he
got into trouble yeah by by sacrificing
it just doesn't work I think rookie for
what
that's a cool move Wow Wow
that's a very nice move and immediately
wins okay that probably also wins but
okay Queen f6 is not actually that clear
yeah the thing is I mean Queen e6 I
didn't see anything here right now what
a terrible game I probably really
shouldn't play that early in the morning
it doesn't help at least
yeah and now this this is actually
really really not clear I mean maybe I'm
not even in good shape Ian the more I
look at looked at this the more I felt
it's problematic
yeah some so here I should win with King
g4 I couldn't quite bring myself to do
that f5 and then going back okay
so this this is the way to do it yeah
yeah okay
I kind of see the point here here I'm
getting this back into the game this way
hmm so that that was bad kingi - also
bad v5 bad yeah and now I should win
somehow a king g4 wins that it also wins
so he have to go a form
here Bishop f7 wins but Bishop GA
doesn't that's weird
really what is the difference
kind of stunned that this is such a huge
difference I went here okay so I said
the difference wait
so we should have several King III there
should g6 I mean I understand that this
wins yeah but I don't quite understand
what the difference is - the bishop
being like - the game the should g8 King
III so that also wins then that's a
weird way of what what stockfish is
doing here and the engine is acting we
had edges like what why I said the
difference I mean it's it's just about I
need those two diagonals I mean and way
it's very weird anyway so this is
winning so how did I spoil that that was
probably an unnecessary morally but it's
still so I had to win somewhere here
Bishop c6 is the winner
okay Bishop c6
King here I can take this one no that's
true and then here before here you can
actually do this yeah okay no here weep
why this is running running out of most
our Blake is running out of mousse so
here I spoiled it and had a bit of time
I had a bit of time I should have
invested a bit of time it's not so
difficult when him yeah and he he
manages to manages to draw I was a
pretty bad game pretty bad game what I
did I mean I should really see before I
was there was just very simple anyway
thanks for watching